When Apple engineers pitched Steve Jobs on
turning the iPod into an iPhone, he responded,
“Why the f*&! would we want to do that?”
“That is the dumbest idea I’ve ever heard.”
reported Adam Grant in his book Think Again.
Jobs feared creating a phone would undermine
the iPod, which sold 20 million units in 2005
and accounted for nearly half of Apple’s
revenue that year.
Besides, Jobs thought a phone would only appeal
to the “pocket-protector crowd”.
He was also concerned that mobile phone carriers
would dictate the iPhone’s design and features
and force Apple to make a subpar product.
But those who wanted an Apple phone refused
to give up.
Tony Fadell who headed the team that built
the iPod, told Adam Grant that in order to
convince Jobs, people “had to work as a
group, not simply in one meeting but possibly
over weeks, to get him to change his mind
or to see things from another angle.”
Contrary to popular belief, Steve Jobs wasn’t
a success solely because he bent the world
to his vision.
Much of his success had to do with a willingness
to change his mind.
And his team knew how to get him to do that.
Before the iPhone, just about everyone at
Apple thought cell phones sucked.
Jobs was known to smash his to bits when his
calls dropped.
But pitching to Jobs wasn’t as simple as
saying: Wouldn’t it be awesome if Apple
built a phone everyone loved using?
It involved strategically chipping away at
his resistance.
Two years before presenting the iPhone concept
to Jobs, a small group of Apple’s designers
and engineers experimented with new ways of
interfacing with machines.
They stumbled upon a small Delaware company,
Fingerworks, co-founded by a Ph.D. student
and his professor, who built a touchpad that
interacted directly with the screen.
Apple would eventually acquire FingerWorks
and its patents related to finger gestures.
The Apple team aspired to expand beyond a
touchpad to a full touchscreen, perhaps for
a device like a tablet.
Apple designer Imran Chaudhri explained to
Brian Merchant in his book, the One Device,
“...we want to be able to move things on
the screen like a piece of paper on the table.”
They worked in stealth mode, worried that
if Jobs found out about it and didn’t like
it, the whole thing could get quashed.
After showing the multi-touch demo to Apple’s
chief designer Jony Ive who had Jobs’s ear.
Ive told the team, “This is going to change
everything.”
But he was careful to show it to Jobs privately
because of his tendency to dismiss ideas out
of hand.
Ive explained to Walter Isaacson in his biography
on Jobs: “He might say, ‘This is sh@!,’
and snuff the idea.
I feel that ideas are very fragile, so you
have to be tender when they are in development.
I realized that if he pissed on this, it would
be so sad because I knew it was so important.”
After mulling it over for a few days, he agreed
touch was the future.
But he was still not sold on a phone.
Yet, other phones on the market began to threaten
the iPod with their ability to play music,
like Nokia’s music phones.
Apple then decided to partner with Motorola
to incorporate the iPod into a new Motorola
cell phone.
It’s a pretty cool phone.
Well, actually, the ROKR was neither minimalistic
like the iPod nor slim like Motorola’s popular
RAZR.
It was such a disaster that Wired magazine
lamented on its cover: “You call this the
phone of the future?”
Putting iPod features into a Motorola phone
“...just seemed ass-backwards to me.”
recalled Apple senior executive Mike Bell
in Merchant’s book.
Bell was one of those who had lobbied Jobs
to build an Apple phone for months.
In November 2004, he emailed Jobs late at
night:
Steve, I know you don’t want to do a phone,
but here’s why we should do it: Jony Ive
has some really cool designs for future iPods
that no one has seen.
We ought to take one of those, put some Apple
software around it, and make a phone out if
ourselves instead of putting our stuff on
other people’s phones.
Jobs called him, and they argued for hours.
Bell pointed out it was only a matter of time
before computers, music players, and cell
phones converged.
The team believed that if they made the product
compelling enough, they could influence mobile
carriers to adopt Apple's terms for design,
software, and distribution.
Finally, Jobs relented, telling Bell:
“Okay, I think we should go do it.”
They considered two different versions of
the iPhone.
The first one was modeled after the iPod but
the scroll wheel made it tough to dial phone
numbers.
Jobs humorously added an outdated rotary dial
to the mock-up to show the limitations of
that design.
The second option was multitouch, which was
more akin to a mini-computer.
Jobs was convinced touch was the way forward.
Selecting the material for the iPhone’s
touchscreen was another major hurdle.
Just four months before Jobs planned to reveal
the iPhone to the world, he decided to switch
the screen from plastic to glass because plastic
was too easily scratched.
Engineers were in a frenzy because they knew
they had to find a glass replacement that
would pass the one-meter drop test, and so
far, all the prototypes had failed.
A friend of Jobs suggested he reach out to
Wendel Weeks, the CEO of Corning, an American
glassware company that had once prototyped
a strong, scratch-proof product dubbed “gorilla
glass” but didn’t have a market for it.
When they met, Jobs doubted the glass was
good enough and started lecturing Weeks on
how glass was made.
Weeks boldly interjected, as described in
Issaacson’s book: “Can you shut up, and
let me teach you some science?”
In the end, Jobs was convinced.
But then Weeks said his company didn’t have
the capacity to make the gorilla glass in
its factories, to which Jobs said: “Don’t
be afraid.
Yes, you can do it.
Get your mind around it.
You can do it.”
And Corning did do it.
Weeks told Isaacson: “We did it in under
six months.
We produced a glass that had never been made.”
The day the iPhone came out, Jobs sent Weeks
a message that’s now framed in his office:
“We couldn’t have done it without you.”
And we are calling it iPhone.
Today, Apple is going to reinvent the phone.
When Jobs unveiled the iPhone to the world
in January 2007, it lacked a key feature.
The original iPhone had no external apps.
It was limited to Apple’s pre-installed
apps.
There was no App Store.
Jobs was worried that a poorly written third-party
app would cause the iPhone to crash, especially
in critical situations where someone might
need to call 911.
However, Scott Forstall, head of the iPhone’s
software division, saw the potential of a
rich app ecosystem.
He told Jobs that they could isolate and manage
any security risks.
The push for third-party apps wasn’t just
internal; developers were advocating for an
open platform.
And they got it.
What we call the App Store
Apple officially launched the App Store in
the summer of 2008.
Allowing third-party apps immediately pushed
iPhone sales through the roof.
Four years after its launch, the iPhone made
up nearly half of Apple’s total revenue.
And it still accounts for half of Apple’s
revenue today!
With well over 2 billion iPhones sold, tech
industry analyst and Apple expert Horace Dediu
put the stunning success of the iPhone this
way:
The iPhone is not only the best selling mobile
phone but also the best selling music player,
the best selling camera, the best selling
video screen and the best selling computer
of all time.
It is, quite simply, the best selling product
All because Steve Jobs was willing to change
his mind.
Steve Jobs changed his mind about building
the iPhone because he thought like a scientist.
He had the flexibility to reconsider his views
when presented with compelling arguments.
If you're looking to sharpen your problem-solving
skills and develop a scientific approach to
thinking, I highly recommend Brilliant.
Brilliant is a website and app where you can
brush up on your math, computer science, and
data science skills interactively, and it’s
FREE for you to try out.
In Brilliant's Scientific Thinking course,
you can explore the laws of physics and the
principles of engineering by solving interactive
puzzles.
I like to take 10 to 15 minutes every day
to go through Brilliant’s Logic puzzles,
which I find have improved my analytical thinking.
Brilliant is great whether you’re starting
out on your STEM journey or want to improve
on what you already know.
You can try out Brilliant for FREE by heading
to the custom link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
If you’re one of the first 200 people to
sign up with my link, you’ll receive 20%
off Brilliant’s Premium subscription, giving
you full access to a world of knowledge.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.